oh I'm back I'm so don't weirdo me you
Molly you I had to go make mac and
cheese vida no it's a magnet ignorant
Chocolate alcohol kill you know nobody
eats chocolate in mmm
there's so much chocolate please put
that as the start of the third episode I
will oh honey I know I wouldn't miss
just chewing so you have money
eat the chocolate then Oh Zambia kid
open the chest cuz I'm [ __ ] noob
uh-huh
guys I'm seriously about a half a
million subscriber I don't mark as like
50 but I want to hit half a million I
don't know what to do for the thing Oh
hot is that not isn't isn't the Terms of
Service listen jury against that know
the terms of sir Phyllis ain't like that
I feel like you're lying because I'm a
hobbit you're not a hobbit
you're a wizard wait II I'm a visit I
don't ever what letters your place so
yeah so I should make you a special
drink no my love me no no what
wait what marks say you say your words
Molly no no no don't do it
oh no no don't do it take your big wrong
bottle away yeah maybe yeah maybe he
mark says yes and Bob says maybe that's
a cap oh my god don't post that I'm over
300 but that's the cat it's a cab you
gotta take the cab get it cap but she
didn't take the shot glass though who is
what is that what what
what no it's empty but I can put at
least I have my beer my beer really does
it so like it was I'm tweeting that I'll
tell you that at least I have my beer
it's funny s way it is I think I almost
just rolled into my blue Yeti I need to
I need to relax myself a little bit
sorry but he's moving on my graph this
is the background
t-bob is when you're really drunk you
sound composed when Wade's really drunk
he sounds like the village idiot
wait me I don't know uh you sound like
really aggressive you but you don't
sound super trash like wait does yeah
I'm such a lightweight a pain oh honey
I'll take I'll take another shot of the
beginning this cuz I think I like I'll
feel really drunk but I feel like I just
need to keep up with Wade here because
I'll do one vital I'll do one final shot
with you really mark whoa wait wait whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I'll do one
final shot with you cuz I think I have a
little less than a shot left in my
bourbon okay some marker wait okay let's
get this boat race going left cams
rolling a bit like I probably when I'm
sober I'm gonna add in like the 10
minutes that we've just been ripping
look at the beginning she is so that
means we only have to fill 20 minutes
we're great alright excellent okay ready
he was waiting for a verbal everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome to drunk
minecraft with Bob and Wade wave stride
and to get to the same level that Wade
me and Bob are gonna take one last shot
well I kick it into the hole again hey
party people who cling keys ready for
this I'm not ready Bob I'm not ready
wait my ability to show Bobby already
did it oh I have a beer okay here we go
you're alright
this is the third episode we've done the
same night so far screaming agony before
this is the fifth time we've heard it
tonight because oh it's been a good
night
oh we're in a real good and a night I
was trying to boat you can just and it
exploded you ruined everything I got a
lot of boats in me no God oh no I really
I do want to UM say that I'm sorry that
we got so many breed in the first
episode because you guys are coming back
minecraft at the time to where it's
really drunk minecraft which is what it
was supposed to be and everyone wanted
this so are you happy Internet are you
wanted it's everybody's happy wait what
the hell's green oh I don't know but
anyway this is a boat race I'll try to
remember that I need to actually tell
people what's going on I'm trying to be
ahead but I'm all [ __ ] I shut up wait we
got like we got boats and there's a
course that zombie found and we don't
know what it does and we're trying to
get through it
Bob's winning mark he's not going on the
runway is you're the wrong way okay
relax wait all right
zombie I'm assuming zombies go trigger
this sumbitch all right your mark good
say I'll mark I've crashed into you well
alright then
okay good sucker I'm starting go oh I
broke my boat oh I don't have a little
[ __ ] it
wow this is fast whoa that was like oh
no I don't know if I want to go under
that alright hit the pig in my boat
exploded oh no my body sputters oh come
on the wrong way
yeah probably Oh Yomi way we don't know
I don't yeah jumping into lava that's
bad I don't know we love it just the
right way you know what there's like
little buttons if we were little buttons
oh [ __ ] my boat
god dammit what do you guys do it your
boat there's a squid tentacle twitch ik
if this was like no art arc arc mark yes
mark mark ha ha ha
ah haha I'm totally winning this [ __ ]
oh these buttons they really lose it
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh god there's like Rapids over
here
oh no giggity God oh jeez oh god oh god
oh god
Oh No ahaha I win I'm fine go through
the gate yes or Park you suck I went the
wrong way diam
how's that our fault your justinian try
and catch me mark I've almost died you
catch me I am I'm almost got you whoa
you guys drink whoa whoa whoa what are
you the same thing we drank for the last
episode goddamn wait what's that oh
that's a game I don't want to hit that
I'm a winner oh well I'm honored key
halt or I mean well it's always a monkey
hole a joker but beer now hahaha
mark stupid what is this wait we have no
idea would you like God wait how did you
get hey you guys are drunk I'm Mario
karting your asses
oh god this is kind of a dog damn dick
ulis well I have a bow and arrow so suck
it
how'd you get a boner oh so woosh watch
you suck whoosh oh she can't reduce me
I'm the with deuces woo I am the one who
produ shoes I'm gonna win I'm the one
who would do she's in the UH I'm
drowning I'm the one who knocks I pick
I'm just gonna swiss pockets and co-op
these they all right we could do this we
could do this come on boat Oh son of a
dang it
okay alright hey God wait I okay coming
I'm gonna get you from now on we have to
replace the letter L with the letter S
again do we want to s again no we didn't
ever desire that's the dumbest thing
I've ever heard
hello yes mark and sire nevermind we're
gonna we're gonna switch for that one
remember we did L with K is that what we
did before you stupid yeah L with care
Ike of you you caused me
no I came with you a coma damn it
mmm come and shove it up your tittle
white baby Bob come on mark a house very
coffee glasses I got you mother [ __ ] I
guess there are no Gators a lot of
occasion you said little aesthetic it'll
whatever
wait or should I say cord minion 777
don't call me that only my mommy says it
there's not a lot of words sir I can't
shoot bows and arrows there are no K's
and that either
I'm very strange hey let me get another
one hang on I gotta get another one
wait okay we're gonna replace C with I
see yeah uh uh it sucked
where's your Berkey with I don't exactly
well wait I don't snakes
I don't think that can I love that Ian
can I don't think [ __ ] god damn it
I work never I'd hang out no no no I
don't know replacing Oh with see God
[ __ ] dammit what I don't I I do Contra
Costa Rica's new Kevin look kuba Cobb
you need a slicker see how I could
christus the car this is chicken you're
still nuke still said the the cursor
where me
sure no not no nuke
ah because I could can't get Chris's
man-catching kill me wait no I just to
keep the cocoon your intro now carrucan
good book up if you leave me hahaha code
i am booked up this hepa cocoon could
and it's my name
what Sukabumi petit way number one my
god you can't care whoever quick good
hot am I kidding I could God kidding
what kidding kidding uh when winning was
it was a kissy no no surely know we need
orkut Yanam say joining psyche lookers
identical occurred Minear couldn't I'm
cut of be cats I'm kind of beat at what
I'm cut of Paquette's I could never win
epic okay okay oh but cats McAdams cuts
perfect uh-oh
I get ho the rich rich kid just put C's
everywhere fire you spike in last place
well there there are no season and you
can there wait wait what you could stick
a hip tick occur such Miku levels you
heard me oh no he could put the
translate that cassette ins from mark
that would be great except I
said you can stick up to ku such lucuma
levels how cou under that nanak it make
sense to kill you can is the kink you're
calling me inappropriately wing which is
worse
hey okay a mark suck it oh thank you
I'm on the floating islands market can
this cook at the floating the for
coating island oh I'm back in the cow
let me get new letters hang on
nice speech with F i cob baba you put
good copper wait with LH with F that
sucks I'm doing something fat sucks
G with L no I don't like that Oh with
you no I don't like that I mean oh my
LOD H with elves PE T with F this random
letter generator I'm dying
sounds very uh uh uh fit for hat fits is
poopin I don't fade one I'm so so now
you guys there's food boom it's so
smoking oh you're so drunk game or you
you you fake fur grafted grand fid the
apply fur don't T there's no sign more
markiplier oh it I'm winning I already
wanted you always either two differences
of
messages know who I was in the sky land
the farm beam old told us I already fun
therefore doing fill the house of Bob
what have we become
what if we what have we become
what if we perform this [ __ ]
fifth fifth use to be such high quality
comics and us to be drunk for a year
oh [ __ ] since zombie he teleport me in
front of mark so I can be famous - oh no
ever hola
ouch I didn't show all I spawned back at
the stupid parkour thing on back Bobby
Cobb is so the far away Oh
Jasha fog lava Oh bah ha ha ha I think
are weird this star that's Bodhi oh I'm
gonna come in second I came in second
hahaha Oh God apparently left shift
doesn't sprint it this mount why both I
can't take it I can't figure what are
you thinking thank you everyone for
washing Oh ten minutes in oh we're like
a goddamned forever we just start farted
in 20 minutes ago
oh he just farted far start food [ __ ] my
my my clock we've gone 25 minutes
counting the bull shift from before
then there's have more men if when I
wasn't here and apparently bill duffle
fell let's build a house yay all right I
have any ideas and stuff this this is
the entrance I just splatter everywhere
to the how that last shot was a mistake
what is this Oh Bob go over here Jesus
I've come here we're above the hill
right by there right by here I'm all
over thank you
climb come over here wait come here come
here come here wait wait wait wait we're
over here over over Bob just got
teleported
no II know I didn't I just ran dude
what's all this then
well what is this what is can we write I
just burped
let's now real three two one go
ah remotely big pyramid like what's the
pig pyramid where we had to race to the
top it gets so I just stopped running we
were racing you know what yeah whatever
wait you remember the picture teleporter
what does she I didn't do anything
yeah wait just cuz you're not looking at
the screen doesn't mean we teleported Oh
God
but he remember the pig pyramid where we
rode pigs up the dog yes Wiz oh yeah
that yeah yeah you know what's a weird
thing to think about that yeah that was
like two years ago
you're kidding me no she's oh so way do
who are not just kidding you we're back
to episode 2 which is actually like 77
of drunk with a flying craft dude like I
just want to say and this isn't drugged
be talking or maybe it is buzzed like
it's been like the most awesome time
play with you guys just [ __ ] around
like I'm so glad that like this worked
out oh yes these are the worst episodes
ever posted people will love it I've not
even saying about these of these
episodes are
terrible bleep wait cuz this is like
started out is just like an idea and it
turned into something bigger and like
that one zombie a baguette the damn race
of the jumping why did you die cuz Bob
shot me with an arrow am i back here
oh okay I see I'm doing hate I just want
to say you guys are awesome and like you
guys watching her awesome cuz some
people watch your from them you're all
awesome LARC catch me a look look at you
uh-oh [ __ ] oh well you're not dead okay
buh buh buh buh buh buh I couldn't kill
you I'll catch you again okay see ya hey
I'll kill me so it's more dramatic
I know okay so just thank you everybody
so much for watching thank you Bob and
way do you have any parting thoughts um
check out Bob's channel and there's just
friction below um I also run a channel
and Mark runs a channel which you
probably know cuz you're watching on it
and check out Vox Populi a zombie check
out Fox populated zombie letting run an
awesome server they put up with our
[ __ ] they demo Papa's are [ __ ]
and there's tons of a mark Bob Wade fans
there's if you want to find people like
you people I don't mean that in a weird
way but you should check it out yeah Bob
Bob Bob hey Bob oh I accidentally hit my
mic and muted it about a minute ago
oh how I said a bunch I don't I was a
gallon I don't know what every way you
guys were ignoring please cut down I
just pulled so much no harm but I was
like ten times they here they come ten
replays
yeah very happy way sorry I've watched
myself drool please cut it out no it's
already done ways you can say all you
want it's already there look at how many
arrows the weight has weighed our
borders Annie's halfway in the ground
apparently they are they so much for
watching we'll be playing more drugs
minecraft in the future baby not this
shrunk but god damn this was fun Oh get
everybody thanks Bob and Wade as always
you see you in the next video bye bye my
god mark no that one
hey guys are you in the ground
haha how do you use a crowd oh my god oh
man what what just happened did we do
the bow release oh yes we did and
wonderfully yeah I'm so I'm so out of it
right now I'm not even sure what's
happening I got got wait infinitely just
ruled happen my body and Bart's not
gonna carry and zombie I'm interested in
your honest opinion of that one was that
too sloppy or was that still on the
funny side of drunk
it started funny and then it got really
sloppy at easy what was it at all funny
tortillas hilarious guys doing anything
and just talking like how you guys are
talking just slow up on it good good
good
I hit my teeth on my bottle is there a
remedy for that is your finger still
broken no it feels great I almost
knocked my mic over I didn't even notice
that I hit my mic but I hit it so hard
that I muted it and almost knocked it
off my penis is drenched in Yingling in
my chest cool you're lucky I'm still
recording my mini-me is this drug is
iron oh [ __ ] okay cut right right good
good